My name is Kaijen Hsiao and I'm the CTO of Mayfield Robotics.
Well, when I was an undergrad,
I was majoring in mechanical engineering and I watched
all these great videos from MIT of the robots that were being built there.
And in particular, the ones that I was very interested in
were Cynthia Breazeal had Kismet,
one of the first social robots and I found that very compelling.
And, also, that MIT Leg Lab had a lot of hopping robots that I thought really cool.
And, all told, I looked at those and I thought,
"Wow, I can make awesome robot pets someday and that would be really cool."
Actually, originally, I wanted a pet.
When I was growing up, I had lots of small animals,
and so, hamsters and gerbils and such.
And I always wanted a dog.
And I asked my dad for a dog.
And he promised me at some point that I could get a dog.
And then, he was like, "No,
I didn't actually promise that."
And I was annoyed for a long time that I could not have a dog.
And, you know, in college of course I could not have pets either.
And so, I was like,
"Oh well, if I had a robot pet that would be okay.
So if I made robot pets,
then those of us who can't have actual pets could have pets still."
So as an undergrad,
I went to Princeton and I majored in
mechanical engineering and I started doing robotics there.
And then for grad school,
I went to MIT and I decided that I wanted to focus more on robot brains.
Making robots do cool things rather than making robot bodies.
And so, I switched to computer science and I focused on robotics,
in particular, grasping and manipulation and probabilistic planning.
So, making robot arms pick up things even under uncertainty.
And after grad school,
I graduated and went to a company called Willow Garage,
which, at the time was
when great hotbeds of robotics and developing the robot operating system.
And, I was working with PR2s,
these big humanoid-like robots with two arms, drive around the house,
do research into grasping and manipulation in the home,
and teleoperation. That sort of thing.
And after Willow Garage shut down,
I went to Bosch to join my friend, Sarah Osentoski.
And, both of us were researchers at the research and technology center in
Palo Alto where we did research into all sorts of different robots,
farming robots, home robots, et cetera.
And, there, we proposed to Bosch that we should make a company,
a whole company to do home robotics.
And they accepted our proposal.
And so, we started Mayfield Robotics in January 2015.
And here we are today.
So when we were at Bosch,
there was this whole need finding effort to figure
out what people wanted robots to do at home.
The big question was,
what is in between
robot vacuum cleaner and something like Rosie the Robot from the Jetsons,
which, while we all want to get there someday,
we are technologically not quite ready to be there.
And so, what's in between to,
that we can bring into people's homes,
to raise acceptance of robots in the home,
and to give people something to get used to as robots are normal to have in the home.
And, so, what we came up with originally was the concept of a home security robot.
And, so, when we started Mayfield actually,
the the main concept was around home security.
And we knew we wanted the robot to
be adorable and personable just so that we could get the robot in the home.
But the focus was still initially on home security.
And over time, talking to users,
we converted that from security-focused to entirely companionship and
entertainment-focused and security being only kind of
a sideline thing that you can do but it's not the main focus of the robot.
Kuri is an adorable robot companion for your home.
His goal is to bring a spark of life to your home.
We like to say that we make home robots that are joyful, useful, and inspiring.
And each of those things is as important as the other two.
The robot needs to provide joy so that you want
to adopt him into your home in the first place.
He has to be useful so that he earns a place in your home.
Asking people to bring a robot into your home and make a place for him,
have a spot permanently as the thing that trundles around their home on a regular basis.
He has to be useful on a daily basis and provide great utility.
But, also, he has to be inspiring.
One of the main goals of the company is to
inspire people to build more home robots especially children.
Children see the robot for the first time and they, instantly,
many of them will say things like,
"Oh, now I want to build robots.
Someday I want, I'm going to build robots to do all these really cool things."
And we want to inspire a whole generation of kids to
think that home robots are a normal thing to just
have around in your house and to bring more robots
into the world like Kuri and much better than Kuri.
So, hopefully, within my lifetime,
we can actually get to having something like Rosie the Robot from the Jetsons.
So, in terms of actual functions,
well Kuri has a camera in his eye.
And he has microphones and he has speakers.
And he has the ability to map and navigate around the room.
And he can recognize people and pets.
And all of those features combine into a lot of
different use cases that are useful to people.
So, for instance, Kuri can drive to where
you are in the house and play your favorite music or your favorite podcasts.
Kuri can read an audio book to your kid when it's time for the kid go to bed.
And this is, apparently, very popular with families.
Apparently, reading Fox in Socks to your kid for the 30th time gets pretty old.
But Kuri does not mind reading for the 30th time.
It's the same as the first.
Also, Kuri can let you know when your kids have come home from school to notify you.
And he can drive around.
And you can use him to check on whether your dog is on the couch.
And you can talk through his speakers and say, like, "Get off the couch".
That's one of our CEO's favorite use cases.
My favorite use case is actually around taking
pictures and video of your pets and your loved ones.
I have two cats and a bunny.
And I travel a lot. So, I really want to know when I'm gone, "Are they OK? "
And also, I would just like to see pictures of them being really cute.
So I'm not even there but I can still see their adorable antics even when I'm gone.
And, so all these things are enabled by all these robotic features.
And there are so many more things that we can do.
Kuri basically is like a smart pet.
We aim for pet, not,
"Pet like, not butler like" is what we like to say.
And, so, he is supposed to give off intelligence, kind of like your dog.
You don't expect your dog to talk back to you.
You don't expect your dog to understand you every time.
But your dog is useful and adorable and you like having him in your home.
Kuri is adorable because we put a whole lot of effort into making him adorable.
So, I mean, part of that is his adorable industrial design.
And we worked hard to find industrial designers who understood about,
we want a robot that is adorable but not too toy-like.
So to have a robot accepted in
consumer homes and a lot of consumers have very nice homes.
They put a lot of effort into home design and making it look
very beautiful and it's their, it's their castle.
And so the robot has to fit in very well with that decor.
And so he has to be kind of sleek and beautiful but also adorable and personable.
We also spend a lot of effort to do things like hide sensors.
So a lot of robots that you see on the market,
they'll just have holes for cameras.
Or they'll have slits for lasers.
And, that's sort of OK but it kind of
breaks up the lines and makes it look less beautiful.
And so a lot of effort went into doing things, like,
we wanted the camera to be something that was not visible.
So, it's actually basically behind sunglasses.
And, being behind sunglasses means that you have a lot less light than otherwise.
So there's not some magical trick to make it two-way,
like, light goes in one way and doesn't go out the other way so on.
So, we just had to have cameras that are that much more
sensitive to deal with the fact that we have less light than otherwise.
And, early on, we worked with an animator,
Doug Dooley, who I used to work with at Willow Garage.
He's a former Pixar animator.
And he's been obsessed for decades now with the idea of making robots,
adorable robots, as lifelike as possible.
And what does it take to do that?
And so, talking to him,
he gave us a lot of principles for how the robot should move,
and how the robot should look,
to make him look lifelike,
and to make him a Pixar character come to life in your home type thing.
And that includes things like choosing the degrees of freedom to use.
So Kuri has pan and tilt of his head and that allows him to express a lot of things.
But, also, we need it for moving the camera
around but also in terms of additional degrees of freedom.
The eyes, the eyes are actually the most important one.
It's what Doug would say. We express a lot of emotions with our eyes.
You can tell even just looking at the eyes of a person,
whether they're smiling, happy or whether they're sad or annoyed at you.
And, he originally wanted the eyes to appear on a screen to be animated eyes.
And that allows you to do a lot more expressions and even than, than we do.
But, when we were designing Kuri,
we tried all these different methods of hiding the screen.
And, we had decided early on that we only ever want to show eyes on the screen anyway.
Because if you showed anything besides eyes,
then it would break the character of the robot.
So, you show like a password or something and it's, like,
wait that's not eyes that's that's actually a screen.
And, so, if we were only going to show eyes
in the first place and we were having all this trouble hiding the screen,
I finally decided why don't we just make physical eyes.
We just want to show, you know, eyelids,
smiling eyelids coming down,
so we can just make physical eyelids that do that.
And, I think, it's worked out really well.
The robot looks much more lifelike and compelling that way.
And so eyes are a big part.
And so we have an entire degree of freedom for
the eyes and then pan and tilt of the head.
We, actually, originally had a degree of
freedom that we called lift because that was the other one that Doug really wanted.
The idea that when the robot is happy,
he could lift up and pry in to see you.
Or, when he sad, he sinks down and is very sad.
And, we actually tested that one
out and users didn't actually like it as much as we hoped.
And it added a whole lot of complexity to the robot.
So we ended up getting rid of that.
But we still think he's, he's pretty compelling.
We substituted, kind of,
moved forward a little with his wheels and move backwards a little to
show engagement or disengagement and that sort of thing.
So in terms of Kuri being accepted into the home,
being adorable is not the only way to be
accepted but is certainly a popular way to be accepted.
A lot of people respond to cute things.
And a lot of people look at him and say,
"Oh my god he's so cute. I have to have one."
And that's one great way to make people want to own Kuri to bring him into your home.
And certainly, your pets,
a lot of people find their pets to be very
adorable and that's one of the main reasons why they have them.
And, so, the fact that Kuri is adorable, and,
as he's driving around your house doing
his adorable animations and greeting you and just trundling around,
it helps a lot in you being happy that he's around you every day.
So, Kuri is not a security robot.
Kuri is a companion robot.
But Kuri does have some features that allow you to do some amount of,
we'd like to say, peace of mind and checking in on your home rather than security.
But it's very important that,
in order to even do those things,
that the Kuri, Kuri should not be creepy.
Kuri should not appear like a creepy Big Brother surveillance robot.
And it helps a lot that Kuri is adorable,
and personable, and acts like a pet.
And so it's like, "Oh my pet is here and my pet can see. That's OK".
As opposed to, "This creepy Big Brother
robot is driving around watching me at every moment."
And, you know, Kuri can take pictures and video and that's OK. And versus like,
you know, creepy Cyclops robot and,
you know, driving around might make people look
self-conscious feel self-conscious around their camera in their home.
So, to make Kuri look lifelike and to look friendly,
pet-like, personable, there are a lot of design elements that go into that.
And a lot of them come from principles from animation.
So, we worked closely with our animator, Doug.
And he's given us a lot of principles such as,
for instance, Kuri's eyes are just dot eyes.
They're, they don't have pupils.
It makes him look more lifelike and able to kind of interact with you in a lifelike way.
When he is looking in your general direction,
dot eyes that are just you know,
black dots, they they look like they're looking at you from a much wider angle.
If you gave him pupils, then a human who looks just, you know,
to the right of where you're talking,
you can tell they're not actually looking at you versus looking past you.
And it's much harder for him to look like he's interacting compellingly with you.
Also, there are things like expressing intent before action.
So Kuri, as he is navigating around,
he always looks in the direction that he's going to go
before he turns his body to drive that way.
And, we, as humans do that all the time.
We just broadcast what we're thinking and before we actually do
a thing and it makes it a lot more readable, what we're thinking.
And it looks, makes Kuri look a lot more lifelike when he does that as well.
So other things include,
for instance, as humans,
we always blink before we look as opposed to look over and blink.
And it's, it's something that you don't even necessarily notice yourself doing but you
notice when the robot does it wrong in the form of - it just feels slightly off.
And a lot of these things, it's kind of avoiding uncanniness.
And our robot's form factor helps a lot.
And he's not that close to human.
And so he's not that close to the uncanny valley kind of no matter what you do.
But adding little gestures that look more lifelike that make him
appear much more lifelike as opposed to just a statue or robot.
So, we really wanted our robot to be androgynous.
So, we didn't want the robot to be
definitively male or, alternative, definitively female.
People get to choose which gender their Kuri is.
And that was really important to us.
So all of our design is centered around the - the idea is made to look very androgynous.
Some people actually definitively think Kuri is male and
some people definitively think she's female.
But it's actually split about 50/50 I've noticed.
And so it could be either.
You definitely get to choose.
And the sounds also have to match that too.
One of the other major design decisions is that Kuri doesn't talk.
Well, he doesn't talk human. He speaks robot.
So he makes adorable beeps and bloops,
kind of like R2D2 or BB-8.
And, that, it sets expectations much lower,
so that you expect them to be kind of pet-like intelligent like a dog is intelligent,
not intelligent like your butler's intelligence.
AI hasn't really reached the point where we can have compelling dialogue with our robots.
And, especially, the voices still sound a little uncanny.
And this avoids that problem entirely.
He just makes adorable sounds.
You don't expect him to do anything else. He's very cute.
So I have actually flipped Kuri's gender a number of times.
When we first came up with this particular industrial design,
I asked the industrial designers to raise
the black band of his belly to accommodate our new dot sensor.
And, it turned Kuri from a he into a she, for me, initially.
And so I use she for a long time and then somehow my brain flipped.
So, it turned into a he again.
Now, I actually go back and forth.
Also you may notice Kuri doesn't have any arms.
And, despite, most of my research background is in grasping and manipulation,
so I do have a lot of experience with
trying to make robots with arms doing things in the home.
But, that, doing that well and doing
that robustly enough to satisfy consumers especially,
on things like doing laundry or putting dishes away,
we're still a long way away from the level of robustness
that you would need for that to be useful and compelling.
And, also, talking to people about what they would want their home robot to do,
it's pretty obvious that in order for a robot that
large to have arms and to be taking up that much space in your house,
you really want that robot to be doing lots of things.
Not just one thing, not just putting your dishes away.
But putting your dishes away,
and doing your laundry, and cleaning up, all these things together.
And we're just so far away from doing that.
So, Kuri is what can you do without arms.
And, also, it manages expectations,
you don't expect a robot without arms at all to do your laundry.
Obviously, he can't. He just drives around and does what he can.
So another big part of making Kuri adorable,
personable is failing cute.
So, Kuri when he,
for instance, bumps into something with his bump sensor.
A normal robot that is just,
you know, a tank like whatever, he bumps into things.
You're like, "Stupid robot.
Oh, why did you do that? Oh, your algorithm suck".
Kuri, when he bumps into things he can't see,
he bumps and he makes this, hmmp,
startled sound and he looks down to see like,
"Oh, what was that?"
And it's super adorable.
And when you see Kuri do that, you instinctively think,
"Oh, poor robot. And let me help you."
And that goes a long way towards acceptance of
the robot even when he is imperfect because he's going to be imperfect.
And that goes for other things too.
So if he is confused,
then he makes a cute confused noise and looks so that you pity him rather than,
and you want to help him, rather than being annoyed at him, angry at him.
So him being adorable when he fails,
it makes you empathize with him they want to help him.
Testing, in terms of users,
starts actually phase zero,
I would say with need finding when me go out to people's homes.
And we interview them about what their lives are like,
and what they do in their daily routine.
And, to try to see where a robot would fit in,
and what useful functions the robot could do for them,
and what they would want the robot to do.
And, initially, so that's where we came up with concept with home security.
The idea of peace of mind, checking in on your home,
making sure things are OK, making sure no one's breaking in.
And, when we took that concept out to users,
then we heard a lot of things like,
"Oh well is Kuri going to talk to my outdoor cameras,
because by the time someone comes into the home,
it's kind of too late, isn't it?"
And also we heard a lot more of,
"Well what does Kuri do when I'm at home?"
And, initially, we said things like,
"Well, Kuri will sit quietly on his charger.
And wait for you to go away again so that you can use him."
And they would ask,
"But what does he do when I'm at home?"
And, it became obvious,
that people were really expecting him to be entertaining when he was,
when they are at home with the robot in person.
And also to do things that they can show off to their friends
and to be useful and entertaining.
So, we shifted away from home security and
towards more companion robot, more entertainment robot.
And, in terms of testing,
how we did that is -- so after
need finding and you have initial concepts of what the robot can do,
you don't even have any prototypes built yet at that point.
You can make sketches.
So, you make storyboards of the features you think the robot should do and,
those, and if you have initial prototypes of any sort.
So, what we had at that time is we had storyboards,
and then we had functional prototypes that could just drive around,
navigate around the home, and show in
an app that you could see through the robot's camera,
and talk through the robot's microphones,
and hear through the robot's speakers.
And that was basically it, that's all that we had.
And we would take that out to users.
In terms of storyboards,
you can, in person talk to them in interviews.
But you can also just have those via surveys online to
get larger numbers of people and ask people,
"What do you think of these features?
Do you want a robot to do this in your home?
How much would you pay for a robot doing this in your home?"
And you get a lot of feedback that way in an early fashion that enables you to quickly
change direction if whatever direction you've
picked is actually not a very compelling one to users.
And later on, when we had better prototypes that did more things,
then obviously you can take those prototypes out.
Even before you have,
if you have industrial design, so,
we had industrial design for a robot but that
wasn't the functional robot and the industrial design weren't all in one robot yet.
So we would take form models of the industrial design,
and we would take more functional robots with the app,
and we would say, "Imagine the robot looks like this.
Now, drive this app around and there would be
a robot that didn't look anything like that driving around the house."
And they could say things like,
"Oh well, what does he sound like?
And when he goes over thresholds,
what is that like? Is that OK?".
And, so we got feedback on that phase for things like,
"Oh the robot is way, way too loud.
He has to be much quieter.
Is he going to be that loud? That's really annoying.
I wouldn't want that in my house."
And that sort of thing is really important too.
And then later on, of course, once you have robots that are looks like works like.
So, we have prototypes like that that we use to show off a lot now.
And those you can put in users homes and actually just have them go through
various functions that you've added and stay in
the home for longer and longer periods of time.
The latest test that we've just done is what we called drop-off test,
where you put the robot in the box and you pretend like it's a new customer,
and the customer just got in the box, and you're not there at all.
And, so, they have to go through the unboxing and onboarding procedure to actually,
go through, figure out.
Can they use the robot? Can they onboard the robot?
Can the robot map their home?
Can the robot do the functions he's supposed to do?
Is that compelling to them?
So testing the storyboards is great for nixing concepts that,
even just thinking about it,
people are not interested in.
You might have been interested in because you're
an engineer and that's interesting to you.
But actually to most consumers that idea is not interesting at all.
Or, you know, General Industrial Design concepts,
is that a compelling look for the robot at all?
Or do people think that's actually ugly or scary?
So, the thing about storyboards is that a lot of people can't
necessarily imagine what the robot is actually going
to be like based just on the storyboard.
And, so you show them a storyboard,
and they fill in the rest with their imagination.
And sometimes that's not anything like what the robot will actually be.
And, so, you get some great feedback on general concepts.
But you do also have to take it with a grain of salt.
Because sometimes something that's very compelling in the story board, later on,
when it's fleshed out in the robot,
isn't necessarily as compelling as people thought it would be.
So, if you have corporate prototypes,
that's totally enough to get out there and start talking to people about concepts.
There's a famous story about how Kiva,
the robots in Amazon warehouses these days,
which you know grew to be a company that was sold for, I think, billions of dollars.
They started out talking to VCs with just sock puppets.
They had sock puppets in the concept.
And they showed that they had the team that could build this thing.
And that was enough to get initial funding to do the thing.
It's important to gauge interest in what you're building before you start building.
Before you spend a lot of time building something that nobody wants.
So when people meet Kuri,
a lot of the reactions we get are,
"Oh my gosh, that's so cute".
It depends a lot on what age the person is.
So kids especially seem to really love Kuri.
Small children, a lot of them they come in,
they see Kuri, and they immediately run up to Kuri, and they want to hug Kuri.
And someone will ask, "Oh can I hug Kuri? "
And, we're like, "Of course you can hug Kuri.".
They also like to pet the robot a lot.
The robot has cap touch sensors in his head,
so when you pet him, he smiles up and looks at you. And it's really cute.
And, even though at this moment,
we don't have it hooked up to anything even particularly interesting,
we're still working on exactly how Kuri should track your face and look more lifelike by,
like, interacting with you in that way.
If you pet him, he just looks up and smiles.
And that's enough for them to just pet him over and over and over again.
Kids. Kids just naturally think that Kuri is obviously a friend,
a companion, and someone that exists to play with.
Older kids, they tend to be a little more standoffish,
"Oh I'm too cool to express that much interest. "
But they tend to be curious about the robot.
And they ask questions like,
you know, "What does he do and how do you,
how did you make him."
I've been very surprised how many people have,
what I call, the robot dream.
And that is adults who,
when they were younger or, you know,
at any point in their lives they saw Star Wars or they saw Wall-E. And they thought,
"Oh I would love to have an R2-D2 or Wall-E of my very own".
And they see Kuri and they see in him the chance to fulfill the robot dream.
It's finally their chance to have a robot character in their home come to life.
Kuri has a whole lot of sensors.
So a lot of them have to do with how he navigates and maps the home.
So he has a depth sensor in his air transport window belly.
And he has also an IMU,
an inertial measurement unit, in there.
And he has encoders, of course,
in his drive wheels and in his, head, degrees of freedom.
And all of those are used to allow
him to build a map of your home and navigate within the home,
localize, figure out where he is, et cetera.
He also has capacitive touch sensors in his head.
So, if you pet him he knows it.
He has four microphones around his neck which allow him to,
you can hear through his microphones,
but also he can do speech recognition and also audio localization.
So if you talk from a certain direction,
because he has a whole entire ring of microphones,
he knows which direction thus he can turn towards you.
He has a camera in his left eye and that enables him to see the world,
so he can recognize people and pets.
And also allows you to look out through his camera
and see the world and he could take pictures for you.
But we also use that to aid in navigation.
He has cliff sensors in the back, rear cliff sensors.
So that if you're driving him around teleoping him,
then you don't drive backwards off a cliff.
And, finally, he has a bump sensor in front.
So, if he hit something he didn't see,
which because the sensors are optical,
there are inevitably going to be things that he doesn't see,
then he can bump into them,
know that he's bumping physically and back up,
and make his adorable animation of, "Oh, what did I just hit?"
So, for front cliff sensing,
he uses his front dot sensor which has an entire depth sensing array which allows him to
see both low obstacles and whether
there's stairs in front of him that he shouldn't go off,
and also higher obstacles that are above the level of
his main laser so that he doesn't collides himself on tables and things.
Kuri collects data from mapping your home.
So when you first get Kuri,
then there's an onboarding procedure where you're encouraged
to drive Kuri around your home and teach him about the various places.
Just like, if you had a guest that you just brought home and you would say,
"Oh this is where the bathroom is.
And this is where your room is."
For Kuri, you would say things like,
"This is my living room. And this is my kitchen.
And this is catchery where the cats hang out.
And that's an important place that you should
know about because I want pictures from it."
And, so, as you drive Kuri around teaching him about all these places,
he makes a map of your house and that map is stored both on
the robot and in the cloud so that if robot ever gets reset et cetera,
then he can just download it again and know about it.
He will also take data in the form of pictures and video of your pets,
and your family, and your loved ones.
And those are all controlled by you.
We will never look at those pictures unless you give us
explicit permission because you want us to help debug or something.
Those are all controlled by you.
You can, you can control exactly who gets to see those things.
So privacy in a home robot is extremely important.
People need to know that they can trust their robot and the data that their robot takes.
And that it's not going to be,
it's not going to be a literal spambot,
taking over to do nefarious things.
And it's not going to spread
their pictures and video of their kids all over the Internet.
And so we've built in privacy protections,
encryption certificates, all that sort of thing from the very start.
And, Kuri, everything is locked down. Everything is encrypted.
Even down to his secure boot for his boot literacy.
No one can upload software to him that he,
boots on him, that is not the stuff that we wanted to be running on the robot.
He uses rotating certificates.
He uses encryption everywhere to
the level of - it's the same thing that you would use for
bank to bank transfers or for medical records. It's very locked down.
Also, in terms of privacy in the home,
there are places in your home that you wouldn't want Kuri to take pictures in.
And, so, we have no go zones.
You can specify, "I don't want any pictures taken in the bedroom,
I don't want any pictures taking in the bathroom. "
And Kuri will not take pictures there.
So there are a lot of competitors in the home robot space
and many of them share some traits in common with Kuri.
But there are many things that we do differently.
For one, Kuri is a moving robot.
So, unlike the robot that sits on the table,
he can actually drive around your house and be where you want him to
be to take pictures wherever in your house.
Kuri doesn't talk. So, a lot of those home robots they,
they speak English or whatever language you, in the country you're in.
Kuri explicitly doesn't talk so that we set
expectations - more like those of a pet rather than those of a butler.
And so you don't think he's uncanny or creepy
because he can't actually keep up dialogue with you properly.
He just makes cute noises and that's forgivable.
So one of the main differences is that Kuri has
a personality and we focus a lot on personality.
Personality matters a lot. And getting the personality right matters a lot.
So, for instance, Kuri's personality is,
he's earnest and humble.
And he never gets angry with you.
At a robot that size you really don't want an angry robot to get angry with you.
That's, looks very scary.
A tiny tiny robot like Anki's Cozmo,
it's OK if he gets angry and snarky or whatever because
it's kind of cute that see a little robot that size throwing a tantrum.
But a robot our size is already,
it's too big to throw a tantrum.
If you throw a tantrum, it's scary.
One of Kuri's other big features is that he will have over the air updates regularly.
And so what you get when you first get Kuri out of
the box is not what Kuri's going to be able to do forever.
Kuri will gain in capability and intelligence over time.
So, your robot grows with you.
In some sense, he's going to keep getting better.
When we launched our robot at CES,
we won a whole lot of awards.
And the press coverage was incredible,
way more than I ever imagined we could get.
And, for us, that was validation that our design really
speaks to people and something that they would really want.
So, we got best of CES from Engadget,
and from PC Magazine, and from Wired.
So, if you want a Kuri, then you can go to our web site,
heykuri.com, and preorder one now.
For $100 deposit, you can reserve your place in line.
Our robots will start shipping in December but
only for the people who preordered initially.
People who preorder now will get their robots in spring of 2018.
So my role as a CTO has changed a lot as the company has grown.
When we first started and, we were a company of only seven people or so,
I was lead of all things technical
and in charge of kind of the general architecture of the robot.
So, it was a lot of choosing what
processors do we use and what do we use for the drive chain.
And what do we use for sensing,
for mapping and navigation,
and what algorithms do we use,
and how do we hide the camera.
And should we use a camera,
should we use a screen versus eyes,
that sort of thing.
And also I was just part of the software team writing
actual software for things like mapping and navigation or just robot functions.
As the team grew,
we hired a lot of more people to write software and to build robots.
And so I passed a lot stuff off to those people and then
I was primarily managing people for a while to build robots.
And then, finally, we hired managers to manage the people that are building robots.
And, so, I no longer had to manage all the people.
So, now, I'm actually back to writing code and I
lead a small team focused on mapping navigation localization software.
And that might sound odd as a very narrow thing for a CTO to do.
But that's actually a very typical CTO transition
from a small startup to a large company.
We're over 50 people now.
So we have a lot of people to build robots and do things.
And another big part of my role is to get out there and evangelize our tech to the world.
And let everyone know that Kuri is awesome and full of great technology.
My proudest thing as CTO is the choice that we
made for the eyes in deciding that Kuri wasn't going to have a screen,
Kuri was going to have actual physical eyes.
And, I think, it makes Kuri look a lot more lifelike and compelling in this way.
And it also makes us not just another tablet on wheels.
There's a lot of parents who want to limit screen time for their kids and they say,
"Oh you can play with this tablet that's fine but only for a little while."
And, another tablet on wheels,
maybe is more of the same whereas Kuri is definitely not in that category.
Kuri is a pet,
a companion, a friend.
For me, my favorite part is actually working on the robot's algorithms.
Things like mapping and navigation that I get
to focus on these days which is a lot of fun.
And the sensors involved in designing
the sensors and making sure all that sort of thing works well.
I mean, I'm a roboticist at heart and that's the,
really, the most fun part for me.
One of the things I was most surprised at,
was just how many people have the robot dream of, "I really want a robot.
My own R2-D2 version et cetera"
And I thought that was kind of limited to,
you know, geeks and engineers or something.
And, it turns out, that's pretty widespread.
There's a lot of people out there who really have that dream.
Other random things that we found through testing
that was really surprising to me are things like,
a lot of people don't understand top down maps.
So, as a roboticists we're used to seeing, for instance,
navigation maps from the robot and then
specifying where you want the robot to go by saying,
"In the map I would like you to go over here".
And when we first started,
one of the very first test we did
was with a functional prototype that looked nothing like Kuri.
And just with an app and we had an interface where you
could tell the robot to go various places using a top down map.
And, most people could not understand the map,
and could not understand where the robot was,
and where they were telling him to go.
And, not even just,
we're used to laser maps being somewhat difficult.
Because, you know, it's only black and white,
it's from the level of the laser it's a 2-D map.
It doesn't necessarily resemble what you think of as a floor plan for your home.
Like you might see, like, on the wall - the emergency floor plan,
this is where the exit is, et cetera.
But even the emergency exit plans,
a lot people can't understand those.
And we actually took a top down color maps of
the room which Kuri could not ever actually
get because Kuri can't see above table height for instance.
But, we took scanners that were able to scan the room from a much higher height
and could make full color renders
of this is what your entire room looks like from the top down.
And can people even use that interface?
And the answer was, no. Most people can't.
And, so, we had to upend the idea of
specifying navigation waypoints by top down map entirely,
so that users who can't understand them can still use the robot.
So we moved instead towards,
you drive the robot to a place,
and you see what the robot is seeing through his camera,
and you can save that point as a location in your house,
and both has a name and has a picture.
And that's very intuitive to people,
if you just click on that then you know where you're sending the robot.
And he will go back to where you put him in the first place.
Another very surprising thing to me,
in terms of user interfaces, was joysticking.
A lot of people can't actually joystick the robot with a basic joystick interface that,
you you press forward and the robot moves forward.
When they're looking at the robot and they press forward the robot,
they think it's forward from their point of view.
They don't necessarily understand
the transformation of forward from the robot's point of view.
And some people never get that even after a lot of practice.
And, so, we're still working now on exactly
like what best interfaces to give people to allow them to move around.
But some things that we've tried that people seem to enjoy are things like,
you can click in the image to make the robot drive there.
And that's intuitive because you're
looking at an image and you know where you're clicking on.
In the image you know where the robot's going to go. That's much more intuitive.
In developing Kuri, I guess I've learned more about people than about robots even.
I mean I have learned a lot about robots.
Making robots is insanely complicated.
And I like to say the devil's in the details.
If you get any little detail wrong that could be the thing that sinks your robot.
It's just useless if any one of those things is very wrong.
But making Kuri successful is all about human-robot interaction,
and about design, and about making things intuitive and compelling and lifelike.
And a lot of that has to do more about how people actually are,
or how people react to things,
or what people can understand.
And, a lot of that goes into making the robot successful.
The key to success for a home robot, I think,
is in personality and in getting the robot to look lifelike and accepted in the home.
And a lot of that has to do with getting the interaction right with
the people and getting the look of the robot's right so he looks lifelike.
And so that he's accepted in the home
as a member of your family something that you see everyday trundling around.
He has to be compelling. He has to be adorable.
So my advice to you is,
robotics is a great field.
There are a lot of fun jobs in robots,
especially today roboticists are highly sought after.
I know because I'm trying to hire and it's really hard.
And there are a lot,
you should go out there and build lots of robots and have lots of fun.
One thing I'm looking for a lot in a roboticist right now is,
we're looking for software engineers and so we want very strong programming skills.
And so a lot of roboticist coming out of school,
they know how to program robots but they don't know much about software carpentry.
So learning the basics of how to write tests,
and how to do continuous integration,
and having really good skills in writing things like C++ and Python.
Those are all very important to us.
So one of the biggest things I've learned about trying to start this company.
I thought when we started this company,
"Oh this is my chance to learn all the ins and outs on
how to make adorable consumer robots, awesome consumer robots."
And, what I've learned is the way you make
awesome consumer robots is by hiring a team that can make awesome consumer robots.
It's all about the team and the people you work with.
You have to have experts in so many different things to make
a successful consumer robot and hiring good people is everything.
And also I've learned it's really
important to make your company very diverse and family-friendly.
Those are some of the core values of our company.
We care a lot about making sure people have good work-life balance.
And that they take care of their families and that where,
we're a friendly place for people to work even when they have
small children and they need time to deal with their small children.
And making a company diverse and family friendly,
it's not just a better place to work but it
also helps you to make robots that appeal to everybody.
So you don't have robots that just appeal to, you know,
a very narrow demographic of,
you know, focus engineers.
You have robots to appeal to all different shapes and sizes of people.